autrement cathy c'est toujours la même
c'est une grande compétitrice une
professionnelle à part entière une fille
qui sait ce qu'elle veut et qui se donne
les moyens pour y arriver elle a des
défauts elle et les faux ah oui elle
doit avoir des défauts elle va avoir des
défauts mais là je ne trouve pas sur le
coup le judo féminin français n'auraient
peut-être jamais été ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui sans cathy arnaud depuis 11
ans déjà l'orléanaise a tout gagné sur
tous les tatamis
aucune autre judoka pneu peut afficher
un tel palmarès quatre fois championne
d'europe
deux fois championne du monde et
pourtant peu nombreux sont ceux qui
savent
telle est la volonté d'un sport à nulle
autre pareille qui réclament de
l'abnégation de l'agressivité de
l'humilité cet allant dans le sens
bordelais natale là où elle a gagné ses
premières ceintures que l'on découvre la
vraie valeur de 4 post 1 700 habitants
entre landes et gironde une petite gare
oublié d'être est transformée en dojo où
viennent rêver
future championne cependant avant de
choisir l'art martial kate a longtemps
hésité
la double championne du monde de judo
aurait pu en effet choisir le football
pas étonnant de la voir chausser des
crampons avec ses frères ses copains
qu'il accueille avec fierté chaque fois
qu'elle s'échappe de sa vie de
championne ici en tout ça mais s'ils ont
des casiers d'une vedette qui retourne
dans l'espace sous son ère son accent
c'est un secret depuis plus de dix ans
loin très loin de paris ces salles de
sport et ses embouteillages
c'est un honneur extraordinaire pour une
collectivité aussi petit que la nôtre
d'avoir parmi ces armes ça quelqu'un qui
fait une carrière aussi brillante
à tel point que vous lui faites soutenir
la comparaison avec le personnage le
plus illustre en france et oui puisque
dans cette salle il nous avons
obligation d'avoir le président de la
république qui est dans mon dos lorsque
je siège au conseil municipal j'ai en
face de moi
cathy arnaud et sa médaille d'or tous
être faits sont ici mieux que des cartes
postales
celle que l'on a laissé s'envoler
quitter le pays pour traverser le monde
n'oublie pas alors votre famille c'est
combien de personnes à bien ses dix-sept
petits-enfants cc on n'entend plus une
soeur et cap frère et c'est un village
aussi c'est si une famille je crois que
tout le monde ici à hostess se connaît
en forme une famille comme dangereux
club et je crois que c'est important de
garder deux c'est ce lien là et cette
force là qui qui qui me manque
énormément quand je suis tout seul sur
antenne
je leur dis souvent aux gens d'ici qui
la veille qu'à la télévision on ne voit
rien à la télévision il faut y aller aux
entraînements pour voir vraiment le
travail qu'il faut faire les sacrifices
qu'il faut faire pour arriver où elle
est arrivée
sur la route de barcelone quasi
emportera soutien à autre on attend mais
on sait déjà
je prétends à la médaille d'or je crois
que je suis vraiment le talus le dail
olympique
je veux finir ma carrière sur sur un
résultat pour qui veut dire que j'ai vu
puisque qui tout gagné championne de
france et d'europe